[Musique]
le nouveau centre d'incendié et de
secours des avirons a été inauguré ce
jeudi 23 août
situé sur un terrain de 3714 m²
l'investissement total s'élève à deux
millions cinq cent mille euros financés
à 80% par le département et 20 % par la
commune des avirons
je suis un homme heureux parce que avoir
une quinzaine de cette qualité pour nous
c'est que du bonheur et pour le citoyen
et c'est quand même un moyen de dormir
sur ses deux oreilles et être tranquille
au niveau de la sécurité
cette caserne était une nécessité parce
que mon projet contient le
renouvellement la réhabilitation et
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
des pompiers de la réunion nous avons
engagé un vaste plan de construction des
casernes et de renouvellement des
équipements ce soit les équipements
roulants comme les équipes en sécurité
les conditions de travail qu'on doit
offrir aux sapeurs pompiers ces
conditions de travail de leurs têtes
excellent le centre de secours et
d'incendié accueille 19 sapeurs pompiers
professionnels et quinze sapeurs
pompiers volontaires qui travaillent
désormais dans de meilleures conditions
comme j'ai pu voir les locaux sont très
adaptés donc dit qu'on arrive au niveau
des engins sous leur mise on passe
directement à l'arrière sans sortir du
bâtiment
et c'est utile surtout la nuit quand il
fait un peu frais et je suis tout quand
il pleut ou en période cyclonique
mais sinon c'est très bel outil qu'on à
disposition et qu'il faudra maintenant
maintenir pour que ça reste il s'agit de
la troisième n'augure à sion du caserne
cette année après celle de saint pierre
en juin et saint-andré en juillet
suivront celle du port et celle de saint
benoît au quatrième trimestre
[Musique]